[Musique]
ce congrès avec avec vous et donc nous
commençons la table ronde dont le titre
aujourd'hui et pouvoir et coopération
décentralisée la république dans les
territoires et donc pour cette table
ronde nous avons donc la chance cet
après-midi d'avoir jacqueline gourault
avec nous qui est donc ministre de la
cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales ont également geneviève
darrieussecq qui la ministre des armées
chargées de la mémoire et des anciens
combattants
nous avons également marc et pierre
vedrenne qui est donc député européen
nous avons également jérôme sourisseau
qui est président du département de la
charente et enfin avec nous nous avons
vincent chauvet qui est qui et maire
d'autun nous allons donc commencer sans
plus tarder cette table ronde et je
propose à chaque intervenant de bien
vouloir commencer leur intervention je
passerai tout de suite donc la parole à
jacqueline gourault qui a donc cinq
minutes pour nous présenter à la fois si
l on est d'accord
le projet de loi qu'elle prépare sur la
décentralisation les fameux 3d et elle
peut effectivement aussi nous faire part
des contrats actuels qui existe entre
les collectivités et l'état
donc c'est à vous je vous passe la
parole pardon il fuse et moi je voulais
le faire démarrer le le comment dire
voilà pardon est ce que je dois vous
alors
d'abord je voulais vous dire que ce
petit film convient gloire est tout à
fait formidable est révélateur de je
crois ce qu'attendent les français
les citoyens c'est à dire à la fois la
proximité est à la fois l'efficacité et
je commence par cela parce que au fond
je crois que lorsque le président de la
république a annoncé à la suite de la
crise
des gilet jaune une nouvelle loi de
décentralisation
bien sûr c'était pour répondre à ce
qu'avaient exprimées les gilet jaune
c'est à dire ce besoin de proximité ce
besoin d'efficacité
mais très vite à ses 8
j'ai moi même ajouté romo
décentralisation les mots
différenciation et les mots des
concentrations qui que j'ai ajoutés par
réaction par connaissance je dirais du
terrain et toutes les concertations que
j'ai pu faire
depuis le lancement de ce projet de loi
m'ont confirmé dans l'esprit de ce que
j'avais annoncé et qui est venu ce qu'on
appelle la loi 3d voire 4d puisque le
premier ministre jean castex a rajouté
le mode et complet fixe ication
c'est-à-dire simplification bien
évidemment pourquoi parce que nous
sommes déjà dans une république
décentralisée
je le rappelle est inscrit dans la
constitution depuis le début des années
80 et confondre comme le disait
tocqueville le peuple français se
distingue par sa passion de l'égalité et
pendant longtemps on a cru que au fond
le meilleur garant de l'égalité
c'était l'état et qu' il fallait au fond
appliquées par tous la même réponse pour
assurer la plus grande égalité des
français alors comme je n'ai que cinq
minutes je vais pas faire un long cours
d'histoire mais vous savez bien que
l'état ou sens très fort de ce que cela
représente en france avec son histoire
particulière un état
eux et à la notion de nation bien
évidemment fait que la population
française a ceci de particulier et vous
savez vous n'avez qu'à le regarder
ils s'adorent leur mère ils adorent
leurs pouvoirs locaux qui sont beaucoup
mûri il participe aux élections pour il
même si la dernière fois c'était dans un
contexte particulier ils sont épris de
liberté locale
il demande aussi qu'on respecte
l'identité de leur territoire
mais en même temps et vous le savez bien
aussitôt qu'il y a un problème
une inégalité et bien on se tourne vers
l'état c'est un réflexe extrêmement
français pour dire que fait l'état
comment ne résoud pas ces différences ou
ces crises entre les français donc je me
permets d'insister là dessus parce que
c'est quelque chose qui est pour moi
très fort et la crise qu'ovide bien là
en plus montrés très fortement donc la
décentralisation d'aujourd'hui comment
doit-on la concevoir
eh bien on doit la concevoir j'en suis
sûr certaines différemment de celle qui
a été faite par gaston defferre voir par
jean-pierre à parra qui déjà avait
trouvé comment dire certaines
difficultés à faire de la
décentralisation au sens de faire du
terme car comme je l'expliquais souvent
naturellement quand gaston defferre sous
françois mitterrand à des styles et des
sites et de la décentralisation
on partait d'un état extrêmement
centralisé jacopin moi j'ai connu cette
période bien évidemment et jérôme qui
fait aujourd'hui président du conseil
départemental
on disait général à l'époque s'il avait
été président avant la descente
lisa sion de faire ils n'auraient pas
présider le conseil général c'est
préfère qu'il présidait donc on a changé
d'époque avec les grandes lois de
décentralisation de gaston defferre
mais comme je le dis souvent la
décentralisation ne peut pas être un
mouvement perpétuel
il ya un moment où on se heurte à la
tente des français d'un état n'est enfin
comment dire d'un état qui assurent ses
missions régaliennes et qui doit les
conserver
et vous voyez donc ce qu'on doit faire
aujourd'hui c'est d'abord et surtout
voir ce qui peut encore être
décentralisé et qui peut être confiée
aux collectivités territoriales alors je
lis et ça peut faire partie du débat que
tout le monde de toutes les strates de
collectivités c'est à dire le bloc
communal les départements et les régions
pense en général qui sont les meilleurs
pour avoir la nouvelle compétence qui
est éventuellement pourrait être
décentralisé je prends par exemple
l'exemple de la transition écologique
via tout le monde se sent le meilleur
pour le faire donc il y a aussi le sujet
des relations horizontales des
collectivités territoriales entre elles
c'est très important et puis je crois
aussi qu'il faut et c'est pour ça que
j'avais parlé de déconcentration je
pense qu'aujourd'hui ce à quoi sont très
attentifs les élus français et par voie
de conséquence les concitoyens c'est
avoir un et à réorganiser sur les
territoires parce que les français
adorent l'état français quand il est
déconcentré
c'est à dire ils les français sont
contre l'état centralisé les jacobins et
sert à égal
paris technocrates etc c'est quand vous
leur parlez de leurs sous préfet ou de
leur préfèrent ils sont très partisans
d'un état sur les territoires mais par
contre d'un état et vous le savez bien
ils demandent qu'ils soient plus
lisibles
parce que la période précédente les
vingt dernières années celui d'hier
concours complexifier la présence de
l'état sur le territoire avec les
agences qui sont apparues ici ou là avec
des administrations et dans la crise du
coc vide on l'a lu les ars qui n'ont
aucun lien pas digne insuffisant avec
les préfets dont il y a aussi le fait de
réorganiser des tas de changer l'état
dans sa pratique dans sa méthode et puis
il ya bien sûr la différenciation et je
termine là dedans parce que je dois déjà
et à mes cinq minutes
la différenciation ça c'est très
important
malheureusement je regrette comme tout
le monde et comme vous tous que nous
n'avions pas fait la réforme
constitutionnelle puisque la réforme
constitutionnelle aurait permis de faire
une véritable défiance iations
naturellement le cela ce que l'on va
faire
c'était il ya déjà un projet un projet
de loi organique a été voté au sénat et
je tiens à préciser que le projet de loi
organique qui a été voté au sénat c'est
le tête du gouvernement
je tiens à le préciser c'est à dire
qu'on va passer par une expérimentation
on peut faire à comment dire a à droit
constitutionnel constant mais qui
permettra puisqu'on met fin à ce côté
binaire qui était aujourd'hui quand vous
faites une expérimentation
elle ne peut
roux d'un certain homme on allait être
pérenne que s'ils voulaient tenter à
l'ensemble du territoire français ce que
nous faisons dans ce projet de loi
organique c'est que on casse ce côté
binaire et peut si l'expérimentation
marche à autun on n'est pas obligé de
l'étendre aux territoires en tout
territoire français ou en charente
maritime
bien évidemment ou pardon jeunes
viennent dans les landes
et donc c'est fondamental et par cela ou
pearl est au fond la différenciation il
sera moins large que ce que la révision
constitutionnelle aurait permis mais
paraître ans qui permettra véritablement
de mieux respecter les territoires voilà
j'ai parlé combien de temps je crois le
double mais c'est important en avoir un
propos vraiment introductif et qu on est
effectivement le point sur la
décentralisation la déconcentration et
qu'on puisse effectivement avoir tous
les éléments et aussi la différenciation
puisque c'est ici que le projet de loi
sur lequel ou travailler et on va
bientôt travailler aussi à l'assemblée
nationale le projet de loi organique
je souhaitais avoir aussi l'avis de
geneviève darrieussecq justement sur la
quête de la déconcentration puisque le
ministère des armées a une vocation sur
le territoire bien spécifique et donc
nous serions très très content de
pouvoir vous entendre sur ce sur ce
sujet là si vous en êtes d'accord
mais bien sûr que je suis d'accord
bonsoir à bonjour à toutes et à tous
effectivement je viens de dire chaplin
est particulièrement essentiel et
l'articulation entre les les
collectivités les territoires et des
citoyens surtout l etat ce sont des gens
que et des enjeux quelquefois difficile
à maîtriser
dans certaines zones du territoire
par des jeux politiciens mais qui serait
si utile de façon apaisée afin qu' il ya
les concitoyens soit dans les voiles à
reçoivent les services vaxy mom est une
enfin des politiques et qui s'occupe
vraiment de façon très positive
c'est le commentaire que je voulais
faire après est ce qu a dit jacqueline
pour moi ce que je trouve assez bon de
noter c'est effectivement l'exemple de
mon ministère
mon ministère il est à la fois très
concentré et c'est un ministère régalien
et très déconcentré trade est concentré
sur tous les territoires de france
peut-être que beaucoup ne le savent pas
mais c'est le plus grand propriétaire
foncier public français celui qui a le
malheur c'est 700 270 mille hectares à
peu près et 55000 bâtiment partout en
france sur tous les territoires de la
france ce sont des bases aériennes ce
sont des des bases navales ce sont des
casernes ce sont des écoles ce sont des
lycées ce sont des centres de formation
et cette présence militaire en fait de
ce ministère régalien sur tous les
territoires est indispensable pour le
ministère bien sûr parce qu'il faut des
conditions d'entraînement particulier
pour certaines unités ou certaines
armées mais il faut aussi des des
conditions particulières arables mais
c'est important aussi pour les pour les
territoires et pour les collectivités et
en ne remontant pas si loin quand nous
avons eu les grands bouleversements du
livre blanc de 2008 qui a préconisé des
évolutions dans nos armées et qui a
entraîné des fermetures de bas
des fermetures d'unités même des des
fermetures des transfert de certaines
activités
eh bien chacun sur tous les territoires
ça a été très très mal vécu les élus ont
été très mobilisés pour essayer
d'empêcher ces évolutions qui
malheureusement bon se sont se sont fait
progressivement
heureusement le ministère des armées
remontée en puissance en terme
budgétaire depuis 2010 est heureusement
il ya aussi des évolutions qui sont
nécessaires notre ministère et nous
avons stoppé certaines certaines
fermetures programmées et nous avons
même enrichi certains régiments qui
permettent de redonner du souffle à
certains territoires et pour tout dire
on voit là que l'action de l'état dans
un ministère régalien sur les
territoires à la présence de l'état sur
les territoires par un ministère
régalien est quelque chose qui est
d'abord est important pour la population
important pour les territoires est
important pour les élus locaux
bien sûr c'est une coopération qui est
une coopération qui est permanente
permanente avec les maires permanente
avec les intercommunalités permanente
avec les départements aussi voir les
régions quand il s'agit d'industrie de
défense mais et cette coopération permet
d'une part de répondre aux besoins les
armes et désarmez vous et désarmez ce
sont des hommes et des femmes et
familles et des enfants dont permet de
répondre à ses besoins et ce sont des
crèches des écoles des besoins et les
armes et permet vous permettent aussi de
répondre à des besoins des communes des
besoins fonciers par exemple est donc
cette coopération entre un ministère
très régaliens est vraiment le terrain
est plat absolument essentiel
donc je je je crois que dans dans cette
présence territoriale de nos ministères
régaliens
il y à aussi bien une affirmation que la
nation les tailles partout et là la
république et par tous représentés dans
le temps ces territoires
bien entendu nous avons besoin de
poursuivre tout cela emilson en cours de
décomposition de la limite de certains
ministres à sion centrale puisqu'il ya
encore beaucoup de concentration
parisienne en administration centrale et
là aussi c'est une volonté forte de la
ministre des armées dont en oeuvre
progressivement avec et bien des grands
services présentent des ressources
humaines qui partira en province par
exemple enfin il ya plusieurs exemples
de ce type est là aussi et bien tout
simplement ça vient renforcer l'idée que
l'on a de besoin d'eux d'abord de
d'assurer la vitalité des territoires
mais aussi de cette relation forte que
l'état doit faire parce qu'avec grâce à
ses ministères régaliens sur les
territoires alors bien sûr il ya le
ministère de l'intérieur et la
gendarmerie sont partout sur le
territoire et la police bien sûr mais
les actions ne sont pas les mêmes que le
ministère des armées
en tout cas c'est la preuve que nous
devons continuer à travailler pour
continuer d'articuler nos ministères y
compris régal hier afin que comme le
disait jacqueline on n'est pas le
sentiment que tout se passe à paris que
tout se décide à paris et que est bien
des territoires sont absents de cette
réflexion et ne participent pas à la vie
de la nation
j'ai fait cinq minutes bravo
bravo merci beaucoup pour pour 7 pour
cette intervention qui permet vraiment
d'illustrer quel est le l'action d'un
ministère sur les territoires est
effectivement que les territoires sont
aussi acteurs de leur développement
maintenant nous allons avoir le regard
européen de marc et pierre vedrenne à la
fois effectivement sur le fonctionnement
européen avec ce fameux principe de
subsidiarité
merci beaucoup de revenir sur cette
définition du principe de subsidiarité
et de voir effectivement comment peuvent
sarc s'articuler les compétences
ça peut être aussi ça a été évoqué
précédemment sur le biais de la
transition écologique par par jacqueline
gourault ça peut être un billet
d'explication donc je vous laisse la
parole pour cinq minutes
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup et le dis
bonjour à toutes et à toutes ravies déjà
d'être à vos côtés pour parler
évidemment d'une question qui est
sensible aux oreilles de tous les
bretons et je me souviens d'un échange
qu'on avait eu aussi avec jacqueline sur
ce point et elle l'a bien illustré et je
voudrais d'abord rebondi avant de
repenser la question européenne sur un
mot qui a été employé par jacqueline
celui de l'efficacité
parce que là aussi c'est vraiment je
pense l'enjeu il faut pas qu'on oublie
dire aussi que l'organisation
territoriale
elle doit être au service d'une vision
et dû construire ensemble et je crois
que souvent ça on oublie de le rappeler
notamment dans la région
justement pour faire de la politique
peut-être avec un plus petit et moins
avec un grand p donc de redire que
justement l'enjeu d'une réforme en terme
d'organisation
c'est bien aussi au service d'une
politique avec un grand p et des
ambitions pour vivre réellement ensemble
et on sait que justement elle doit aussi
servir cette réforme va reconstruire la
confiance bien sûr comme ça a été dit
entre les élus déjà aux mêmes et entre
les citoyens et les élus
alors effectivement il ne dit rien de le
dire il faut jamais oublier que l'union
européenne elle fonctionne sur un
principe qui illustre justement tous les
enjeux avec ces négociations c'est le
principe de subsidiarité
c'est à dire que on confie la compétence
à l'échelon qui est le plus apte à
répondre à la problématique
et souvent comme j'aime bien le dire on
dit souvent c'est la faute à bruxelles à
paris mais au niveau européen c'est
toujours la faute justement à cette
technostructure que ce serait pousse l
on a un peu confrontés à la même
problématique justement alors que je
vais prendre cet exemple de tous les
enjeux relatifs au pacte vert justement
on voit bien que si on veut être
efficace pour le coup là sur la scène
internationale pour entraîner avec nous
de puissance tels que les états unis et
la chine
mais on doit avoir une ambition commune
et cette ambition commune elle doit être
fixée à l'échelle de l'union européenne
par contre pour pouvoir comme ce été
cité dans l'exemple tout à l'heure sur
la rénovation thermique pour
retravailler sur les écoles taxiteurs
bella ça sera plutôt à l'échelle locale
et l'union européenne il faut pas
oublier que bien sûr elle a des
politiques aussi qu'ils sont réellement
commune notamment la politique agricole
commune et sur justement cette ambition
de nourrir les ordres de travailler pour
faire en sorte d'avoir aussi une terre
qui nourrit soit nourricière mai
unitaire qui soient préservés il faut
justement qu'on travaille à l'échelle
européenne dans cet âge là et là aussi
parce que je prends l'exemple de la
bretagne la bretagne au travers de la
politique agricole commune mais aussi au
travers de la politique de cohésion
européenne a mis en place des mesures
agro-environnementales climatique
justement c'est bien parce que ces
projets et ces mesures ont été soutenus
par l'union européenne parce que ça
réponde aux objectifs du crédit et parce
que ça répond aussi aux attentes et aux
aspirations des citoyens avoir une
politique agricole commune petit puisse
nourrir tous les bretons et les
bretonnes et même au delà et qui protège
notre terre donc on voit bien que
l'union européenne justement elle fixe
des grands cas pour pouvoir être
efficace sur la scène internationale
et c'est là où je pense que cette notion
d'efficacité qui a été cité elle est
extrêmement importante il faut toujours
l'avoir en tête et qui nous permettent
de répondre aux attentes et aux
aspirations du citoyen et dire justement
que le principe de subsidiarité
cette notion est l'essentiel aimons
oublie souvent aussi quand on parle à la
fois de lalart 3d mais à la fois l'union
européenne
c'est que l'enjeu ce n'est justement pas
de l'uniformiser mais d'essayer d'art
moniz et au maximum les choses et je
pense que c'est une notion une
distinction qu on n'est pas souvent trop
en exergue uniformisation n'est pas
harmonisation et je pense que si on le
redit les gens sont tout à fait comprend
capable de comprendre que justement
l'enjeu c'est souvent d'harmoniser mais
clairement tu as d'uniformiser et pour
ça la devise de l'union européenne
justement elle elle explicite bien s'est
unie dans la diversité
la france s'est aussi imposable s'est
il ne faut jamais oublier cette unité
qui nous permet d'avancer et jamais
oublié cette diversité qui est source de
richesse et qui nous permet d'aller plus
loin donc l'union européenne et un est
un bon terrain justement qui démontre à
et qui peut être le parallèle de la loi
traduit parce qu'on voit bien que sur la
scène internationale on a besoin de
cette unité européenne comme la sur la
scène européenne et sur la scène
internationale
on a besoin de cette unité française
mais à des moments mais on a besoin de
laisser la place à les territoires parce
que parce que justement les deux
prochains intervenants vont bien le
démontrer
les élus locaux les compétences aussi
des collectivités territoriales
permettent de répondre aux
problématiques aux attentes des citoyens
qui sont extrêmement nombreuses et qui
mérite d'apporter attention allait avoir
cette ambition commune de tous les
échelons pour répondre à la fois au
pacte vert est à la fois grâce à
retisser cette confiance merci beaucoup
marie-pierre puisque en plus ça me
permet d'avoir la transition parfaite
pour maintenant me tourner vers donc le
président du conseil départemental de la
charente jérôme sourisseau qui est avec
nous effectivement sur ces questions
d'harmonisation d'uniformisation
d'unités de diversité finalement on voit
bien que c'est un équilibre qui peut
parfois être
difficile à trouver peut-être est-ce que
vous pouvez donc revenir sur la la
collectivité que vous dirigez le
département dans notre organisation
territoriale il a été un petit peu
bousculées ces dernières années qu'en
est il aujourd'hui et dans un cadre où
les les régions elles vraiment eu un
périmètre beaucoup plus grands
finalement au jour d'aujourd'hui comment
est ce que vous voyez
l'apport du département dans notre
organisation merci beaucoup à vous la
parole
l'essai
or à toutes et à tous très heureux de
participer à cette table ronde alors
j'essaie de tenir les cinq minutes
tout d'abord je le dément le département
a démontré ces dernières années son rôle
essentiel et stratégique dans le paysage
français
il est certain qu'il ya une dizaine
d'années c'était dans l'inconscient
collectif peut-être un échelon assouplie
mais je crois qu'il faut prendre un peu
de hauteur et bien remarqué que les
réformes net beaucoup de temps à entrer
dans les têtes des gens on a des
collectivités je prends ce département
et la commune compte plus de 200 ans
et c'est pas d'un claquement de doigts
quand on crée quelque chose que ça va
rentrer avec une telle légitimité dans
l'inconscient collectif jeunes explique
aujourd'hui les intercommunalités on le
voit elle existe en fait elle existe
beaucoup pour les élus quand on
interroge nos concitoyens les
intercommunalités c'est déjà un échelon
très jeune et en fait qu'elle n'a pas
vraiment encore trouvé sa place dans
l'organisation
si on n'est pas cela la frange des élus
et des responsables consulaires ou de
quelques organismes
donc faut vraiment prendre garde et
s'appuyer là dessus parce qu'au moment
où la société a besoin de repères ou
leurs repères religieux a disparu au
sens religion catholique par exemple
dans les campagnes au sens où beaucoup
de regroupement d'identité ont disparu
on voit cette volonté de s'identifier un
territoire ne bien vu quand on a
supprimé ne serait-ce que numéro du
département sur les plaques
d'immatriculation ça fait un choc parce
que aller avec monde a besoin de
s'identifier faut faire attention parce
que quand on enlève ses moyens
d'identification et bien quelque part il
ya une recherche d'autres choses et
l'autre chose peut-être des choses
extrêmement négative pour se retrouver
donc c'est un peu aussi ce qui a
illustré le mouvement dit gilles est
chaude donc vraiment prudente par
rapport à ça il confortation de deux de
ses échelons de proximité les communes
notamment heureusement on a arrêté de
d'obliger à fusionner on a une démarche
aujourd'hui c'est sur du volontariat
c'est très bien et garde dans cette
démarche là parce que la commune c'est
le premier échelon de on se reconnaît et
aujourd'hui bon si tenté qu'on leur
donne un minimum de moyens pour
fonctionner on verse un rsa on verse un
semis on verse des minima vespa de
minimas pour les
timité et je pense qu'il ya certaines
petites collectivités qui aujourd'hui
effectivement les a6 y ait tant qu'elles
sont jugées trop et des regroupements
mais on voit ici ou là parce que je les
ai vécus en charge des fusions qui
provoque des manifestations même dans
une commune de 128 ans il faut le
prendre en compte je pense que c'est
parce qu'elles sont vingt huit ans que
c'est important
ouais je m'écarte que je reviens sur le
département le département
il a c'est un échelon est essentielle
parce qu'à la fois il a une posture
stratégique
il permet une péréquation interne au
département entre des secteurs riches
des secteurs pauvreté secteurs urbains
des secteurs euros tous les départements
grosso modo à part ceux des grandes
métropoles sont composés de cette façon
là donc c'est un département d'
équilibre qui redistribue les richesses
qui est complètement identifiée dans la
tête des gens c'est quelque chose de
reconnu et qui reste à taille accessible
à la fois par le mode de scrutin des
élus qui permet encore d'identifier
conseiller départemental mais aussi
parce que on est encore pas trop loin
dans notre région que qu'on partage avec
geneviève une région très grande qui je
l'espère demain sera bien mieux
président lesquelles dès aujourd'hui
mais dans une région très grande de
douze départements la taille d'un pays
européen
s'il n'ya pas le département qu'est ce
qui reste qu'est ce que c'est vraiment
une question fondamentale donc je crois
que le président département je suis
aujourd'hui et c'est ici c'est plus une
question et on a vu à travers les
différentes crises qu'on vient
département étaient présents
je rejoins jacqueline tout le monde
attend tout de l'état mais en fait c'est
que l'état s'est pas encore vraiment
coupés de toutes les compétences
je prends un exemple on a des soucis
évidemment dans les ehpad en ce moment
avec des clusters etc
on en est rendus ou la rs pourtant l'air
qui affirme son autorité comme seule
organisation légitime il faut les propos
sont instituées en maître sur la d re
courtoise faut pas aller marcher sur les
plates-bandes de la rs et bien pour
autant la rs n'ayant pas assez de moyens
elle demande au département d'aller
faire le suivi médical qui n'est pas une
compétence du département le suivi
médical dans les ehpad parce qu'elle n'a
plus assez de personnel pour faire le
suivi
là où il ya des clusters elle demande
aux pompiers d'intervenir de l'utiliser
les moyens des pompiers ont des missions
d'état et de santé
et on s'aperçoit que l'état est présent
un peu pour la culture un peu pour le
tourisme un peu voilà est en fait cette
décentralisation qui a confié
effectivement des compétences aux
collectivités alain petit bout needham
outils ou aujourd'hui ben l'état alors
pour peu qu'on ait un préfet qui est
certaine sensibilité et ben ça essayez
toujours de s'occuper de la plupart des
politiques et donc dans la tête des gens
c'est vrai que c'est encore l'état a
encore quelque chose à dire alors c'est
pas la seule explication c'est plus
compliqué et jacqueline d'historienne le
sait mieux que moi bon l'image de l'état
en france il ya tout un tas de choses
qui ne changent pas comme ça mais je
crois qu'il faut qu'on aille à l'est il
faut qu'on aille qu'on n'ose aller au
bout d'une décentralisation et qu'à un
moment donné quand ces deux
collectivités qui s'occupe de quelque
chose on lui donne un objectif on lui
donne un cadre est en liesse
je pourrais prendre des dizaines
d'exemples on a décentralisé la
planification pour l'urbanisme
mais l'état donne les règles donne les
consignes voir les services de la ddt
vous dise qu'il faut mettre des terrains
construits seront vie localement bref
tout ça c'est beaucoup de choses
on a aussi la nécessité et l'âge je le
dis qu'on est là pour dire les choses
aujourd'hui on a une difficulté pour les
collectivités c'est qu'on est en train
de perdre notre autonomie financière
quand même et ça dans le modèle de la
décentralisation
c'est un souci moi demain le département
n'aura plus aucun impôt où il est libre
de fixer le taux pour se financer des
politiques ambitieuses en fonction des
objectifs etc
c'est une vraie question quand même sur
la décentralisation je comprends les
réformes de la fiscalité locale j'y
souscris en grande partie pour la
plupart d'entre elles parce que moi même
je soutiens évidemment le gouvernement
ceci dit là on a une vraie question quoi
demain comment une collectivité peut
dire je j'ai un gros projet je veux
lever la boue rouge est un projet de
diminuer les impôts parce que je vais
attractif et c'est quand aujourd'hui on
va être dépendant uniquement de dotation
fixé par l'état je pense que on a quand
même une question de fond a abordé je
pense que ça sera trop court dans ce
quinquennat mais c'est quelque chose
personnellement qui me déçoit un petit
peu parce que
on voit les limites et enfin un dernier
mot je pense que là on n'a par contre
pas passé loin dans la décentralisation
dans la contractualisation c'est que
l'état en laçant davantage ses
compétences doit fixer des objectifs et
une évaluation de l'atteinte des
objectifs
aujourd'hui on donne une deuxième dgf on
donne on met des actions coeur de ville
le cpr le contrat tendance un vrai que
j'en passe et des meilleurs on en
discute avec les préfets mais on ne se
pose jamais la question de dire si on
fait tel équipement
c'est pour atteindre quels objectifs et
comment là
on a un problème dans l'idée qu'on va
faire un plan pour beauté avec des
objectifs clairs pour des peintures de
charenton
alors malheureusement notre intervenant
à des problèmes de connexion
alors je
je lui proposerai de reprendre la parole
dans un second temps merci beaucoup pour
ces pour cette intervention
je propose maintenant de passer la
parole à vincent chauvet et notamment
monsieur le maire je crois que vous
souhaitiez nous parlait également de la
question des financements et d'une
volonté de voir les financements
simplifiée ça permettra je pense de
compléter la vision d'élu local qu'on
était en train de vous exposer monsieur
souris sous qui a donc disparu mais je
vois je pense qu'il reviendra rapidement
avec nous bonjour elodie merci vos je le
dis bonjour à tous bonjour à tous les
adhérents démocrates et tous les
sympathisants qui nous suivent en ce
moment effectivement je vais peut-être
poursuivre avec des mots qu aurait tout
à fait pu employer le président
sourisseau de savoir comment la
décentralisation est vécue aussi au
niveau financier
avant de commencer je vous rappeler que
notre famille politique
le centre le modem est une famille au
coeur évidemment de l'europe a été
rappelé par mais aussi au coeur la
décentralisation et valéry giscard
d'estaing qui vient de disparaître a été
en ce sens un précurseur y compris au
niveau financier et fiscal dont on
parlera avec la création du comité des
finances locales que les mais
reconnaissent bien avec la création de
la dgf la dotation globale de
fonctionnement qui est l'essentiel des
ressources des communes avec la loi de
1981 sur le vote des taux et la
réalisation des impôts locaux et il a
été précurseur ensuite d'autres lois et
le président qui l'a suivi qui était un
peu moins centriste mais a dit à très
juste titre que la france avait eu
besoin d'un pouvoir fort et centralisé
pour ce faire lesquels auraient besoin
d'un pouvoir décentralisé pour ne pas se
défaire
et aujourd'hui on l'a dit en
introduction avec les turbulences dans
notre société avec les contestations
avaient
le manque de confiance à tous les
échelons et bien cette décentralisation
cette confiance aux territoires c'est
probablement une des clés pour permettre
à notre société de ne pas se défaire
alors j'ai qu'une gouro a été un peu
trop modeste dans son bilan parce que on
a déjà eu et en tant que maire on a vu
les conséquences positives une loi sur
les territoires et en partie la
décentralisation ou décentralisée la
république et le thème de cet atelier la
loi engagement proximité voté en fin
d'année dernière qui permet par exemple
des choses aussi indispensable dans
notre société que de permettre à des
personnes qui ont des besoins de garde
de personnes âgées qui sont ces câbles
des besoins de garde d'enfants de
pouvoir exercer des mandats locaux
une loi qui a donné plus de pouvoir au
maire et qui a aussi clarifié un certain
nombre de points et effectivement on
attend avec la même confiance cette loi
3d moi j'aime bien aussi
4d avec la simplification la dea
complexification la 3d c'est voir la
france en relief et la 4d c'est voir la
france en relief évolué en temps réel
c'est ça la 4e décès on voit l'image
mais on voit aussi l'image bouge et
évolue et j'aime dire j'aime bien cette
idée
et effectivement il ya encore des choses
à voir
sans rentrer dans les détails notamment
au niveau financier et fiscal
je rentrerai pas dans le débat de savoir
si on est plus ou moins autonomes et
simplement faire un constat au citoyen
c'est qu'aujourd'hui le financement des
collectivités locales des communes des
départements des régions est extrêmement
compliqué parce que il y à une
tuyauterie infernale parce que sur
chaque projet nous avons des subventions
de chaque échelon alors je suis d'accord
que département c'est légitimité la
région et d'autres et d'autres échelons
et l'europe mais on en vient parfois et
sur les derniers projets à autun à avoir
des projets qui sont
financé par absolument tous les échelons
de collectivités du département de la
région de l'état parfois d'argence de
l'état comme les gens sport deux choix
européens qui font qu'aujourd'hui
finalement on ne sait trop qui fait quoi
et dans cette période particulière vous
qu vide
on a vu aussi un certain nombre de
collectivités finalement choisir
librement leur champ d'action
un peu fouler aux pieds les lois
précédemment voté loi notre s'attribuer
des compétences très générales qui sont
en théorie l'apanage des communes et
intervenir tous azimuts dans la sphère
économique sociale ou sanitaire donc là
je pense qu'il ya peut-être aussi un
certain nombre de choses à clarifier
autant c'est une petite ville où les
membres de l'association des petites
villes de france et jacqueline gourault
nous fait l'honneur de s'entendre
prochainement pour voir les propositions
on peut apporter
mais je terminerais simplement pour dire
que sur les prochains grands défis qui
nous attendent au delà de la
décentralisation qui est importante mais
nos défis de civilisation c'est d'abord
et avant tout le changement climatique
et comment combattre
c'est ce réchauffement des températures
j'invite d'ailleurs ceux qui nous
rejoignent à regarder ce matin avec yann
wehrling lors du parlement européen
il y avait aussi à wad balanant nathalie
et limaces une table des chats ramos
évidemment une table-ronde extrêmement
intéressante sur sur l'action des
citoyens du gouvernement de l'europe sur
le réchauffement climatique et je
voulais simplement dire que si on veut
tenir l'objectif de réduction de
l'augmentation à 1,5 degré c'est-à-dire
si l'on veut tenir notre engagement
international et morale d'une neutralité
carbone de notre économie en 2050
et bien tout ne se décidera pas à
bruxelles tout ne se décidera pas à
paris et ni dans les préfectures de
département
mais ça devrait être vraiment au niveau
local au niveau de chaque communauté
locale au niveau de chaque commune de
chaque quartier qu'il faudra changer les
habitudes et je pense que les années à
venir seront une période
on aura vraiment est de plus en plus
besoin de s'appuyer sur les mers et sur
l'échelon local pour résoudre les grands
défis de la planète
merci à vous merci beaucoup pour cet
pour cet éclairage
nous avons beaucoup de questions de nos
téléspectateurs ou je sais pas comment
est ce qu'on doit dire quand elles ne
suivent par youtube ou facebook que je
ne sais pas mais en tout cas vous aurez
compris là vous aurez compris le sujet
donc on a par exemple une question vous
avez parlé notamment de la rs et donc
nous avons une question excusez moi je
retrouve le nom de la personne qui a
posé la question sur la rs donc c'est
dominique trojani qui nous demandent
pourquoi ne pas supprimer les ars voilà
donc je vous lance je ne sais pas qui
qui se proposent pour répond d'ores et
déjà si moi je veux bien intervenir
parce que je pense que c'est à moi
d'intervenir
d'abord la première chose que je veux
dire c'est qu'en en en plein milieu
d'une crise sanitaire
on évite de prendre des positions un peu
radical qui ne ferait qu' aggraver la
crise dans laquelle nous sommes
les agences régionales de santé existent
elles n'ont certainement pas été pensé
pour faire face à une pandémie
ça je là je vous la corde elles ont été
pensées davantage comme une organisation
comment dire qui gère la présence d de
la santé sur les territoires mais il est
bien évidemment et beaucoup de questions
nous remonte en ce sens sur le fait que
d'abord c'est une organisation régionale
et que donc elle est éloignée des
citoyens et qu'à tout le mois et cela
commence déjà il y a des représentants
par département qui vont se développer
mais ça ne suffira pas moi je sais
personnellement je le dis là en tant que
militante modèles et en tant que
connaisseur du terrain il faudra
davantage aussi de lien entre les ars
les élus locaux et aussi les préfets
c'est quelque chose de très important et
il faut que ce soit impliqué dans des
annonces des agences que j'espère
départementale davantage que régional
que ce soit impliqué aussi les élus dans
les gestions de cette agence comme on a
impliqué autrefois des élus dans les
conseils d'administration des hôpitaux
qui sont devenus des conseils de
surveillance et qui ont éloigné un peu
les élus je pense qu'il y a et là
olivier viron le cdja il y avait une
nécessité mais de revoir tout cela mais
je pense que cela devra se faire bien
sûr hors crise quand la crise sera
terminée
alors vincent chauvet et ce côté
également intervenir je passe la parole
oui simplement effectivement pour pour
saluer ce que vient de dire jacques kuhn
et puis dire que ces préfets je crois
que c'est cette fois elodie qui le
disait au début auxquelles sont
attachées à la fois les élus et les
citoyens institution créée par napoléon
bonaparte napoléonienne que saluer le
symbole mais aujourd'hui on dépend de
l'état qui ne sont pas sous leur
autorité qui sont un peu indépendant et
c'est vrai que le préfet étant
l'inquiète l'interlocuteur on a beaucoup
parlé du couple maires préfets on pourra
peut être parler
le maire sous préfet donc il y a là un
vrai point de l'état dans les
territoires c'est la plus la
déconcentration de la décentralisation
mais en tout cas c'est c'est le relais
territoriale de l'état
eh bien je pense qu'un certain nombre
d'élus peut-être que jérôme qui nous a
rejoints pour à pourra compléter ce
qu'ils en pensent mais verrait bien
certains interlocuteurs renforcé dans
ses pouvoirs notamment sur les
administrations qui ne dépendent pas
directement de lui il ya pas que la
santé il y en a d'autres aussi qui
pourrait avoir un lien plus direct avec
le préfet
deux départements aux préfets de région
alors est-ce que jérôme se trouvait sous
souhaite intervenir sur ce point
oui oui je rejoins pour les forces qui a
été dit ça allait dans le même sens
parlement donnait une vague de dire on
supprime des sous-préfectures parce que
bon à quoi bon sous le sacro-saint
toujours du nombre d'habitants en fait
kiffer l'alpha et l'oméga de bien des
choses en france à mon avis qui ne
correspond plus à l'air du temps
il doit être corroborées nombre
d'habitants et kilomètres carrés à
s'occuper et peut tuer tout d'un coup on
relativise bien que bien des choses
je crois que maintenant ça évolue et les
sous préfet on envisage davantage leur
suppression en secteur très urbain dans
l'île de france où effectivement
l'identité du sous préfet à mon avis
avec moins d'importance en zone rurale
c'est c'est souvent le seul
interlocuteur que l'on a avec parfois
des organismes d'état qui sont que l'on
trouve qu'à l'échelle régionale et le
sous préfet peut provoquer ces réunions
peut accompagner pour les projets est
aussi un avocat des projets alors c'est
là où on arrive à la limite parce que le
sous préfet le représentant de l'état en
zone rurale il devient aussi le
représentant des zones rurales vis-à-vis
de l'état c'est vrai que sa posture est
en train de changer un petit peu
notamment les soupes pp je rejoins ce
que c'est assez flagrante ni de viana il
se crée un nouveau métier en fait est
fondamentale mais qui montre aussi à
quel point il ya eu un éloignement entre
les élus locaux et l'état parce que
quand le sous préfet le constate
lui-même et qu'il devient l'avocat des
élus locaux auprès d'autres directions
départementales aux directions
régionales
c'est bien que quelque part on n'a pas
pris le bon chemin à un moment donné et
les l'état s'est retirée par coup par
coup de poignard à souder lisation c'est
ça c'est l'évolution des 30 dernières
années pour tak aujourd'hui rescue
souvent que le sous préfet dans sur 80%
du territoire
donc c'est important de préserver c'est
sûrement important de de réfléchir à
l'organisation des tas de l'état dans
les 30 ou 40 ans à l'ombre de ces
constats là parce que là aujourd'hui il
ya un goût d'inachevé
la nature a horreur du vide tout le
monde s'est adapté on va trouver
d'autres modes de fonctionnement mais il
ya des domaines assez frustrant tu as dû
moi qui crée des frustrations et et je
prends à clé tav bien faire il ya une
volonté de faire confiance aux élus
locaux les élus locaux sont des
partenaires sérieux de l'état des
différents organismes
mais dans les relations quotidiennes
c'est quand même
assez compliqué moi j'ai vécu une fusion
de l'agglomération ex-président pédiatre
j'ai dû menacer cinq fois de
réquisitionner un payeur pour que les
payes des 400 agences au verset vous
citer des exemples de blocage des
services de l'état qui sont à l'opposé
des discours et politiques ou nationaux
que l'on entend ou je crois avec vos
missions on veut aider les élus locaux
mais la traduction locale parfois et
complexe on avait aussi la question de
tirer la belle qui nous dit faire
confiance aux territoires
oui et il ajoute avec un mécanisme de
contrats d'objectif avec les financeurs
qui ne serait pas inutile et ça me
permet de revenir sur la question
justement de l'évaluation qui est un
thème qui était cher au mouvement
démocrate
donc sur ce sujet là est ce que l'un
d'entre vous souhaitent réagir
je viens dire justement aujourd'hui on a
de nombreux dispositifs de l'état
contrat de relance contre un plan plan
pauvreté pour direction coeur de ville
beaucoup de dispositifs qui sont plutôt
séduisant intéressant mais finalement on
se fixe des objectifs non 6 pas les
indicateurs pour les évaluer et ça c'est
compliqué et mais je pense que c'est une
démarche dans laquelle on devrait aller
aujourd'hui c'est l'étape sûrement
supplémentaires et qui justifierait
davantage une différenciation des moyens
quand je vois mes collègues du
département de la creuse par exemple on
ne peut pas avoir les mêmes attentes
l'état ne peut pas voir les mêmes
attentes ne peut pas donner les mêmes
moyens d'une formula c'est mathématique
si je pense à la dotation globale de
fonctionnement qu'un département comme
la seine samedi qu'ils allaient lui même
ses propres difficultés
je crois que c'est l'étape aujourd'hui
où tout le monde aime et murs à ça
derrière des moyens il ya des indes il
ya des objectifs des objectifs partagés
avec l'état et doyon boss donné moyen
d'évaluer c'est pas l'évaluation
sanctions bc d'évaluation aussi
pédagogique d'anciens profs que je suis
voilà il ya ya les variations qui permet
de dire on est sur le bon chemin on a
atteint ou se résume cette modalité ne
permet pas d'atteindre les objectifs
je pense que c'est l'étape suivante dans
les contractualisations à venir nous
avons vincent chaumette qui souhaitent
également relève après le lever la main
ce alors honneur aux dames annonces
d'hier avec geneviève et après vincent
chauvet oui merci pour moi je suis je je
je vous écoute tu avais beaucoup
d'attention et beaucoup d'intérêt jeu
franchement je trouve que nous sommes
quand même toujours dans des
millefeuilles complexe que nous nous y
reconnaissons quand nous sommes élus
nous arrivons à fonctionner
avec plus ou moins de bonheur quand nous
sommes élus et que nous avons des
capacités de l'ingénierie ou des
capacités autour de nous à faire des
dossiers de plus en plus complexe et que
tout cela n'est pas forcément on n'a pas
donné pas le signe d'une grande fluidité
pour développer les projets des
territoires et développer les
l'amélioration des conditions de vie de
nos concitoyens je le dis nous avons la
commune nous avons l'interpro vénalité
nous avons le département nous avons la
région et bien entendu avec les grandes
de région est la nôtre avec jérôme est
particulièrement grande et n'est plus
question d'enlever un département bien
sûr mais nous avons toujours des pays
nous avons toujours des contrats d'aidé
contractualisation qui se font avec des
pe dr les fameux pôles d'équilibré
territoriaux ruraux nous avons enfin
nous avons toute une forme d'action
publique qui se traduit par une
complexité en définitive
d'interlocuteurs quand vous avez un camp
voulait réaliser l'équipement culturel
en fait tout le monde a la compétence
culture donc vous faites des dossiers
vous faites des dossiers partout vous
pouvez même en faire des européens si
vous avez véritablement un projet qui
rentre dans les dents les conditions
c'est moi je trouve que tout cela est
une très très grande complexité pour les
élus et tout cela est un frein à la
fluidité on va dire de la mise en oeuvre
de ces de ces dossiers
je ne sais pas comment un jour nous
pourrons améliorer cela parce que et
jacqueline je pense qu'elle partage
beaucoup de choses avec moi là dedans à
nous qui cherchons à simplifier à
fluidifier à rendre souple les les
interactions les choses sont très
complexes et
voilà la question que je me pose c'est
comment simplifier réellement ce ne soit
pas qu'un slogan que ce soit une réalité
quotidienne pour les élus et comment
faire en sorte que d'ailleurs cette
simplification et bien elles soient
perceptibles par nos concitoyens c'est à
dire que leurs concitoyens sont capables
de dire à bien sa tél telle
infrastructure et bien on peut dire que
pour moi là c'est par exemple
département loup c'est parce que à
l'arrivée de façon que les élus des
départements des régions voire même les
cta qui ont beaucoup financer certaines
structures ne se fasse pas d'inquiétude
c'est toujours le maire qui a fait dans
une commune d'ain et c'est toujours pour
ses concitoyens
l'action du maire est bon c'est pour ça
que les gens aient le temps leur mère
c'était peut-être injuste pour les
autres collectivités ou les autres
niveaux qui auront participé mais c'est
comme ça que ça se passe
donc voila moi c'est en comme j'ai été
quand même élu j'ai été maire présente
d'agglomération conseillère régionale
conseillère départementale jeu j'ai je
n'ai jamais vu de est alors quand vous
avez fait un projet en rue vous
n'imaginez pas ce que c'est c'est à dire
c'est d'une faut des ingénieurs à tous
les étages donc voilà je j'aimerais tant
que nous arrivions collectivement à
trouver des solutions pour fluidifier
tout cela
alors ce que je vous propose puisque le
temps tourne donc je vous invite à être
très bref dans vos réactions donc on à
vincent chauvet à jérôme sourisseau et
marie-pierre vedrenne si vous pouvez
vraiment faire une conclusion voilà très
rapide et je laisserais bien évidemment
le mot de la fin à ajaccio gourou ou
vincent chauvet c'est à vous oui merci
c'est exactement ce que je voulais dire
ce que vient d'exploser geneviève et je
le dis d'ailleurs souvent vous paye des
gens très cher pour monter des dossiers
et de l'autre côté on paye souvent aussi
des gens aussi cher pour lire les
dossiers et au final avoir une
tuyauterie est vraiment complexe et je
pense qu'on arrivera à une vraie
simplification
quand on aura au final une vraie
confiance dans les mers ou une vraie
confiance de l'état dans l'échelon local
parfois on considère un peu comme des
des personnes sous tutelle ou on donnera
en bloc au début de l'année une dotation
en dix ans maintenant débrouillez vous
vivez avec cette dotation
faites vos projets et l'évaluation peut
se faire elle doit se faire au niveau de
l'état je pense qu'on sera arrivé aussi
un degré de maturité démocratique quand
l'évaluation
elle pourra se faire par les citoyens
avec les citoyens jugeront si l'argent
public est correctement employés ou pas
et donc pour conclure je voudrais citer
comme cela a été fait en introduction
tocqueville qui doit nous inspirer et
qui dit que c'est dans la commune que
réside la force des peuples libres et
que les institutions communales sont à
la liberté ce que les écoles primaires
sont à la science elle la met à la
portée du peuple merci beaucoup donc
jérôme sourisseau marie pierre védrine
et jacqueline gourault et bien marri
donc j'espère que je sais qu'on va voir
revenir avant la fin du coup je partage
totalement ce qui a été dit par
geneviève parce que dans n'ont pas assez
de directrice de la maison de l'europe
justement moi en tant qu'association il
fallait justement remplir les dossiers
pour chaque échelon et s'était jamais le
même dossier et c'était insupportable et
en fait mon métier n'était plus ma
mission première était de remplir des
dossiers et d'aller à des rendez vous
avec des administrations pour justifier
mes dossiers
et c'est vrai que c'est un peu
incompréhensible et ça crée une part de
frustation à la fois vis-à-vis des
porteurs de projets à la fois vis-à-vis
des élus et donc c'est important c'est
le fait d'avoir de travailler sur
l'efficacité l'évaluation et la
simplification juste peut-être un petit
comparatif européen parce qu'on a mis
sur se comparer en tant que français
oui je suis vraiment d'être déjà les
intervenants qui arrive sur la prochaine
tableau non juste très vite pour dire
que on voit bien justement l'enjeu
d'avancé en terme de différenciation
parce qu'on voit là pour le coup à
l'échelle européenne
l'efficacité par exemple des land
allemand et il faut effectivement qu'on
avance parce que ça permettra d'avancer
mais par contre et pour rejoindre sur ce
que disait jacqueline aussi en
introduction comme ça la boucle est
bouclée
il faut faire très attention aussi dans
toute cette ambition et dans toute cette
volonté de certaines régions d'avoir un
petit peu justement dévoue volonté un
petit peu belliqueuse d'autonomie
vis-à-vis de l'état parce qu'on voit
aussi souvent dans l'échelle européenne
justement par qui sont portées ses
ambitions souvent par des régions qui
ont un pib beaucoup plus fort que les
autres et on oublie les sens même
justement c'est la solidarité qui doit
être d'avoir entre toutes nos régions et
je pense que c'est important de le
rappeler
alors justin où je suis désolé pour
monsieur sow de son vaisseau parce que
on est vraiment très contraints par le
temps on doit vraiment rendre l'antenne
juste un mot il ya un vrai enjeu
aujourd'hui depuis la fin du cumul
on a quand même deux types d lui il ya
les élus nationaux et les élus locaux et
c'est beaucoup moins il ya un combat
l'interaction entre ce type de livre
d'élus depuis les lois de qui on
interdit le cumul c'est un enjeu très
fort pour qu'on
prendre comment vivre les collectivités
comment elle évolue le comment on peut
les réformes et les terres avancé
aujourd'hui on a encore des élus et si
je parle devant jacqueline geneviève qui
ont une vie une vie d'élu local donc
encore prégnante elles le savent bien
comment ça fonctionne ceci dit les
choses bougent vite et aujourd'hui au
parlement et il ya moins sûrement 7,7
parole de la vie des collectivités
aujourd'hui donc c'est un enjeu pour
demain comment faire vivre cette
démocratie locale au sens global pour
mieux anticiper les réformes la
clarification puisque je rejoins
effectivement tout ce qui a été dit la
grande complexité du système qu'on a le
secret dans lequel on vit au jour tout à
fait d'accord et c'est la conseillère de
bill yeux qui qui vous le dit et donc je
passe pour une conclusion si possible
bref j'en suis désolé à jacqueline
gourault j'aurais beaucoup de choses à
dire bien évidemment à revenir mais je
suis d'accord globalement avec il y
avait 10 4 2 choses sur lesquelles je
voulais revenir c'est sûr jeu qu'on a
appelée l'autonomie financière
l'autonomie fiscale qui n'est pas la
même chose et de penser que l'autonomie
fiscale est garante de la
décentralisation c'est pas forcément
comme l'a dit d'ailleurs vincent chauvet
tout à l'heure c'est pas une histoire
française
si je compare avec l'allemagne
l'allemagne n'a pas d'autonomie fiscale
elle a une autonomie financière puisque
chaque année les landes dans les länder
ont chacun leur budget et se
débrouillent avec donc il ya besoin en
france désormais d'une grande réforme
fiscale j'en suis absolument convaincu
dans les relations entre l'état et les
collectivités territoriales et jeudi au
passage à vérone avec la conscience que
la collectivité qui souffrent le plus
actuellement et bien sûr le département
deuxièmement on ne fera jamais jardin
total à la française je suis persuadé
intimement persuadé de ça il n'y a pas
d'un côté les collectivités
territoriales et de côté l'état ça
n'existe pas et au fond c'est peu au
fond au niveau marie pier a dit haut
niveau au niveau de l'europe et des
états membres
et je pense que l'état et les
collectivités territoriales doivent
marcher main dans la main voilà pour
l'intérêt de nos concitoyens
chacun dans ses responsabilités chacun
dans ses prérogatives
chacun évidemment dans ses compétences
et comme l'a dit l'on dit un certain
nombre je crois que si jérôme qui la lie
avec d'arrêter d'avoir des doublons
quand il ya des affaires décentralisée
que l'état ne s'occupe plus bien
évidemment c'est normal mais en tout cas
parfois et vous entendez des forces
politiques dans notre pays et même des
associations d'élus qui en permanence
oppose l'état et les collectivités
territoriales
je crois que c'est extrêmement masque
malsain extrêmement poujadiste et ne
peut mener qu'à des difficultés pour
notre pays merci à tous merci beaucoup
et merci à tous ceux qui nous ont suivis
et merci bien évidemment à tous nos
intervenants pour 7 après pour cette
table c'est vous à bientôt